yeah welcome to this video
yeah the system welcome change from the
daily let's videos yeah I'm going to
present to you three games that I
recently played you know classical chess
tournament an open tournament played in
in Austria was played in the little town
of Russia and the other far Kazi this
tournament is called fart house they
open the lake at fart would be the
translation it's a nice little lake in
the other Austrian Slovenian born in
southern Austria it was a medium-sized
open tournament with about 130 players
and it was some had four grandmasters
competing at a couple of IMS and yeah
I'm very happy to to tell you that I
played a really good tournament and with
the luck needed going to show you the
the final standings I actually won this
tournament which is get a really great
success I had never won one of those
open tournaments I want some regional
championships more than once but it's
never a big tournament with more than
100 participants and you see it wasn't
too bad in the here at the top I will
say that actually winning the tournament
is largely due to due to luck in the
tiebreaks
it's if this you can see there's seven
players at the end with seven points
very often those tournaments um I wanted
by one or two players who score seven
and a half points very rarely you see
eight points but seven and a half is
usually the magic number but here it
happened that seven players got to seven
points and so for the decision who is
going to win it they needed to use a
tie-break system which is here labored
under
take a 1 w TG is datum German a
tie-break fabric one time back to tie
break 3 the tie rack one is the
important one this is boots points which
means the addition of all the points
that your opponent's halves caught which
should reflect if you had better
opposition then than the other players
who are involved in the tiebreak as you
can see at four points on seven place
here the some guy from Spain and Sanchez
he had 49 points forty-nine point five
five fifty four point five so five
points difference which is pretty much
so it's a significant difference I
really had better position than him but
my score compared to second place
Grandmaster malahat Kawau to the guys
after that the Grandmaster Rothstein or
Pardo from Spain was so close it's
basically a matter of luck so I could
have easily finished third for us or
whatever so I'm very lucky to to be the
winner but nevertheless um I played good
chess in this week and I can on show you
three games from the tournament so I'm
going to switch to to the chessboard now
and start them the Creed games this was
played and I think it was around five if
I'm not mistaken around five or six
eloquentia I played YTM against a master
from Austria download spindle book he's
rated close to 2,300 to 280 or something
so his see the master strengths but only
has got a national master title yeah
let's have a look at the game open
Knight f3 here don't be irritated by the
times it was a classical time control of
90 minutes form 440 moves and
two seconds additional per move plus 30
extra minutes at 1840 okay so we have an
English opening here why an idea free
adhere my opponent usually played to
this move before and they had a look at
this and the preparation um but in the
game here he went for c5 and he
afterward some told me that he had some
bad results with Bishop before and in
some games before um which I didn't see
in the database probably some local
games or other game so didn't make it
into the database so he chose to play
something different
um I did mind we now reach a typical
position from the English that is
associated with the the head chakra
setup I played b3 here castles which
should be - all very normal moves and
now I played d6 um this is some typical
for this Hedgehog set up on black has
other ideas in this position he can for
instance also play em the Moose a6 here
the idea being that if white plays
similar to the game you actually have
this this possibility trying to exchange
the knight on d4 immediately this can
also be prepared with green c7 and then
96 this is some quite an interesting
setup in the game he played d6 however
and this is slightly different as we see
deform take stakes and exchanges now of
course 96 is not on because the square
simply not protected
he played Queen c8 which is some a good
news I think and also fairly typical
move the Queen prepares a check on this
where it is often nicely placed the
bishop is gone on b7 but this is also a
good square for the Queen in the setup
it may be prepares this one and clears
the path for the rook um yeah I not
played III uses the idea we had to set
up white once - I can put those on the
board that set up this formation and
complete this with Queen f3 and rook do
you wanna the idea later is to push the
Jeep on and go form yes base gain on the
gun the King side important is that
white is not playing III e4 which is
possible weakness so it's better to keep
the pollen III and have them Center in a
more more stable state um plate night c5
here another possibility is Queen g7 and
exchange twins to this kind of endgame
um this is always possible for black and
it's however pretty um yeah a pretty um
yeah and welcome task to to defend this
position it's it's rather passive black
him can try to prepare those breaks but
it's not easy to accomplish and white
has ways to further improve his position
so this is not a very comfortable
position however it's an option would
like to to be yeah to exchange some
material at least he played 95 it's a
now Queen f3 as planned
um yeah here of course white needed to
be sure that knighted d3 isn't isn't a
problem
if you would have played 93 here I just
have a Bishop III and this Bishop is not
badly placed and the knight will
probably be kicked soon and doesn't
really have anything else than
retreating so 93 is really am a jump
into into thin air
it doesn't really lead to anything an
interesting idea here was to defy
forever that you're needed to to check
the idea being that after taking like an
play 93 here and now of course Bishop
III is not possible
however White has the this reply which
is important attacking e7 with a very
big fork and yeah this is very good for
white now after and move of the bishop
white can just protect his attack Bishop
and has a rather substantial advantage
one funny point is that after a move
like Queen b7 White has got d6 the idea
being that after Bishop takes rook t1
why does simply in excellent shape look
at the default and the strong night um
black is in terrible trouble here
so those brakes here are not working
what he played is the move rook to e8
this is some okay a good move into past
Bishop f8 rook t1 I don't want to worry
about this night jump forever so Luke
t1s is fine and I think here black
commit some the first slide um in
accurate news he played a six now which
is completely normal for the the head
shocked but I think that the immediate
Bishop f8 was probably a more precise
the ideas that after g4 which is the
standard advance IAM
um blacks d-5 an idea he tries to play
the games much stronger as rookie 8 is
far more useful than a six um for
example if you look at I did this kind
of position after Knight f5 there is 94
with the intention of Quincy to check
and black has a really fine position so
Bishop f8 was was better it basically
forces Y to abandon the plan of an
instant g4 g5 push I need to prepare
this a bit not quite sure with them what
moves exactly there are some candidates
so that you can try to get the King out
of it on play h3g form there are various
possibilities
I mean after whoops after visually wait
here White's move this is an idea or
just prepare this slowly the instant
g-force shown is probably answered by a
d5 with a good position this was more
precise he played a six
after which I played the movie freud's
it's really normal in this position I
want to gain space and try to attack
this this night the night also only has
got this heaviness as a possible flight
square for example after Bishop f8 g 597
black must be cautious of this night
only has got b7 assumed as a square
those two pieces two knights a sort of
standing on each other's toes and yeah
white has a rather comfortable position
here I don't have a very concrete way to
progress now but it's it's a very nice
space advantage like it doesn't have any
brakes with me if I were d5 and I can
just improve the position
even a simple move like h4s possibility
still it's a fight it's not winning on
or anything in the game he tried to get
something concrete immediately ended it
it really backfired he played d5 after
that I could just take him Knight takes
he takes d5 didn't really help if you
would have taken with the pawn I play d5
1995 and it's just a pawn
plus I've got excellent pieces look at
that it's a it's very bad for black he
took with the knight takes on d5 85 and
nine f5 and this is the big difference
between the Bishop f8 moves on mu 15 and
the a6 move back with Bishop f8 the
bishop is already on f8 and there's not
a six plate his successor really useless
movie in this position now and Bishop f8
was a very important temple now after
Knight f5 I'm simply threatening to to
take on g7 and he's got absolutely no
choice he needs to go Bishop f8 to cover
the g7 pawn
yeah and now this d5 is just hanging and
I can take it with both pieces after
Queen d5 however I didn't like Luke a7
so much he's got this look d7 idea -
yeah he's some of the pressure it's it's
so good for white but I think what I've
played is better I took with rook and
also on I had some the the vague idea of
what later happened in the game you will
see it won't spoil it I had the vague
idea of this already and it really
materialized
however with rook takes d5 I overlooked
um a tactic here and it was really an
uncomfortable surprise I played this
rather quickly this move and then he
played the 93 which I hadn't really
appreciated the knight jumps into into
my camp and now I cannot really take it
because of Queen c2 check and picks up
the rook I didn't I didn't see that at
all this idea so it was lucky that I
didn't blunder anything it could could
have easily happened okay so I played
Bishop to d4 you know this Bishop was
detected on d4 it has excellent
chances to earn to play a good role here
in the game and so and this is also the
main point of this position why white is
better here it's not so much because of
the the pawn which is nice
but also because of them here the
centralized active pieces in this
position however it's it's interesting
what should black play he played a
Quincy to check which happens to be a
mistake however mid mistake that I
didn't really yeah didn't really use to
my to my advantage
it seems that he should have tried
Knight to be formed after that um the
best news is probably rookie 5 which is
also what I had planned
um the somewhat strange group d6 which
maybe comes to mind because after Bishop
takes Knight takes the knight Fox and
gets back the material
this move is unfortunately met by
something like b5 black just ignores
this this book and
it turns out that Y didn't really
benefit it from route 56 it's um it's
funny that g6 is bad because of the
simple capture as this is a winning
position for White Queen g3 is an
absolutely deadly threat or queen G form
however after oke 6s managed he can just
play b5 and it's not clear what what do
I should do it seems that the simple
rookie v as I had planned
it's better the idea is that after rook
e5 if black takes here white can also
just grab on b6 and retains the extra
pawn it's not spectacular but why does
white is better here this is what black
should have played you should have
played this night before and this limits
White's edge to two normal proportions I
think however he played this check and
this is a mistake but I didn't use it
I didn't calculate this in in a very
precise manner
I played King to g3 here which is the
yeah maybe the most obvious move not
retreating the King but keeping it close
to the pawns quite often in this kind of
positions where the pawns advance the
king is better placed on the 3rd rank
near the pawns then on the first rank as
there are simply lots of yeah let's say
air between the king and and the pawns
however due to concrete considerations
here kingi 1 would have been much better
and in fact this is a very very big
advantage for white and black has big
problems keeping keeping the keeping
alive here and one possible idea is
Queen to g2 if black for example place
moves like that
Quincy - basically forces the Queen
trade and this means that something like
this will happen and here widest is
close to winning this
it's the pawn and it's the pieces it's
just a big activity White has a very
easy game here also the better King
after King g1 a black also can think
about this but this will be met by
Knight XG 7 and will be fine very
powerful and this is a motif to remember
because what he played is after King G
through Sheen 3d played not before and
okay we will see this later after King
Lear er they had a good good opportunity
but one that we both really
underestimated here black should play g6
which looks a bit against ain't playing
g6 here opening the King but it's really
a problem white doesn't have anything
better than 96 and after 96 like takes
it and now plays 95 and this is the
important thing
black intense night before and this
would be a monster night and here you
see the the problem with the King on g3
units it's a big check IAM so white must
take him who it takes and now something
like this and it continues white enjoys
the the extra pawn here four against
three but it's it's still a bit tricky
it's not a very straightforward
technical task because there's the weak
porn somewhat weak porn on III end and
the shaky King so this is what black
should have done to fight on with some
chances to hold
he played night before and okay you
already saw the idea of the sacrifice
and in fact here there is such a
position and I could take on g7 which I
which I did I saw this a couple of moves
before this general idea and in fact
here it works to perfection one point is
that after 95 I can take yet and yeah
like loses the house here just two
points up already and if he but protects
the night for example with queen c6 that
is this powerful move and when it's the
Queen
yeah here it's it's just two points for
for nothing
so it took him oops no he he took the
night Luke g5 and at first you think oh
wait under he's got f6 right f6 Bishop
f6 look a seven and in fact this is what
my opponent had calculated and hoped
that this is good for him
but after f6 you can treat this position
as as a little puzzle and try to find
them to move now it's not so difficult
really but it's still still a very nice
motif I was glad to have spotted that
some moves earlier okay I'll put it on
the board now you have a couple of
seconds though and the move is Queen d7
and this is strong enough to force
instant resignation it's just this big
made threat and if he takes the rook
little mate so we have this this funny
incident where everything is focused on
the on the g7 spot the only thing he can
do to avoid immediate mater's his rook
takes III but if you look at this
it's still this rope hanging so takes
yes
oops and now we have this coming so it's
it's completely over white will made
when wind decisive maturity it's already
a man exchange and a couple of points so
this was some after Queen b7 the final
position he resigned to him um yeah an
important factor in this game also was
the time I played this rather quickly so
he was under big pressure right from the
beginning having spent much more time
than than me a tournament chess I'm a
pretty quick player contrary to get to
some of them the Blitz games so this was
a nice victory here with white and I'm
going to show you another white game
against him yeah a club mate of mine is
very unlucky draw to play someone here
you know so well so let me pull up this
game so I put up that position I won't
do the first 60 moves let's just
concentrate on the important points um a
couple of words about my opponent it's
as mentioned a teammate of mine also
young player he's some I think 18 is
from 1995 so he turned 18 this year if
I'm not mistaken so I'm still a junior
player and promising one is got about
2200 rating at 18 this is pretty good if
you're not exactly Magnus Carlsen or
something from for normal let's say
promising junior this is a very good
rating and his um it's a really good
player still on some room to improve of
course but it's still a very serious
game here I wasn't too thrilled with
this despairing okay so let's have a
look I've got white and this black here
black needs to solve this problem the
miss Ellen is biting on its own porn so
at one point black needs to play c5 and
he played c5 in this position I think it
was a good decision to do so if you play
on a slow move on let's say let's say I
move like h6 just to put it on the board
something like this sees both Knights
controlling c5 and black will never ever
play the smooth so it's really a danger
that you problem that you are too late
with this and therefore c5 is the the
principal choice I took on f6 em2
damaged his pawn structure of course he
cannot recapture like that because then
I can take with the night he took with
the pawn and this is a very interesting
position now how to proceed him um I
think the first move is pretty obvious
why it needs to take and here we see a
very critical moment of the game here my
opponent played the move Queen c6 which
leads into trouble he didn't want to
play Bishop c5 because he thought he
would be a being trouble after that I
actually saw a line here that I thought
was very very cute but it has some
drawback and the line that I calculated
here and it's interesting night a form
this is this is easy of course leading
to a good position for white it's just a
very good structure but black has this
smooth this is much more interesting
threatening mate and here we see that
the computer shows an interesting line
Bishop d5 this is I saw that actually
quite quite a nice move after it takes
Knight takes white is in good shape
again
but he can take here and then not a
floor this was my idea winning this
tempo attacking the Queen protecting g2
and after Queen g5 95 I thought well why
does an excellent shape but black has
got a very funny truth he can play Luke
c8 attacking the knight so let me
protect it so nice anyway and here what
I saw was a 595 and white as a super
shape but black has a very strong move
here which the computer here this
position points out immediately
and this is the slightly strange move
Bishop f3 yeah and this is just just
very strong this rook is attacked and if
I move it he plays d5
maybe oh this is even stronger and I
cannot take here because of made on G -
yeah Bishop f3 is just a very very
strong move that I didn't see he also
didn't see it
I mean um it's a very very strange line
I think at the end white probably should
to just take here and then play a normal
move like like Group C 1 protecting the
Queen so that before can be answered by
95 this is probably a still a very
slight edge for white simply because of
this those those weaknesses what
position is more small solid but it's
nothing too spectacular
so black should have taken on c5 he
played queen c6 but in the process
overlooked something
I played before now because I am
calculated the game continuation however
it seems that here f3 was a good move
which I didn't really take into account
at all um
it looks a look strange if black now
takes here then 95 is a is a good reply
now note that there is no mate or
anything here and black has the problem
now it's this threat and see if I was
saying if he takes 95 it's just just a
very nice position threatening Bishop d5
so f3 was strong but I didn't I didn't
consider this simply because I had seen
this before and after that it's clear
that black is going to play before
Bishop c5 can be answered now with 95
similar to the line we saw before so it
was clear to me that he was intending to
play before the point is after the
capture after this I mean queen c5 Hanks
he's got this very nice shot and black
his son is even yeah probably better in
this position because I'm so strangely
tied up here before this is what he what
he said his hopes upon but white has a
very good reply and this is 95 of course
I don't want to retreat here or grab
them do this pawn 95 is just is just
strong he and the only question is how
strong is it is it leading to a real big
big edge for white or is it just
excellent compensation black really has
no choice he needs to take the piece so
this happened in the game so I
sacrificed a piece yeah to get those to
get those two pawns and they're both
they're both very nicely supported
there's still this potentially very
strong Bishop the knight in the center
protects c5 and the rook is on d1 plus
there's an additional weakness e on on
the
so it's clear that what has an excellent
game but it's not clear if it is winning
the computer actually thinks that what
is better but it's not supposed to be a
decisive thing he now played Queen c8
which is probably mistake but it is very
very difficult to play it seems that
Queen c7 was the better news after Queen
c7 I have from various ideas the thing
is this is a compensation anyway those
pawns I don't need to really rush things
I have a little bit of time to to set up
the pieces in the most convincing way
however the very direct move Queen C for
setting up this attacking battery on f7
it's okay after rook moves d6 BlackWolf
sacrifice back here to get rid of the
pawns check the just to to have a simple
line this kind of position is always
somewhat better for white simply because
of the wiki King here but it's not a
winning the winning advantage it's just
good for white around along these lines
black's defense probably needs to be a
setup however as mentioned Queen C for
years not the only means I can try
various things to to improve my position
in in other ways but since Queen c7 is
better
he played Queen c8 it's of course very
very difficult here and in fact I made a
mistake and this is also the reason why
Queen c8 wasn't the best move I played
and what I had planned beforehand I took
on before and played Bishop to b3
I had planned to moves ago because it
protects the Queen
so that actually d6 is a possible move
yeah after capturing I can recapture and
the Queen is protected I also now have
fixed this weakness on before so that in
some cases I might just grab the pawn
this I had intended so it's more like a
positional way to play a strategical way
but instead I also could have played d6
immediately because after Bishop takes
now you notice the pin I have a Queen
move threatening the mate on f7 made in
two moves so that after this he needs to
go here and I can take and I'm just
winning here with this this passed pawn
also it's an additional pawn an extra
pawn so very a very good position for
wider should win iam d6 was so stronger
but I just played what I had planned
beforehand it's so good for white but
it's not so so convincing here already
played Bishop to a6 which probably after
which you cannot save the game probably
you cannot do it anyway but at least in
a practical game this is just very very
difficult to play the site with the
pawns is just just much easier to to
play the computer actually recommends
f5m the idea being after d6 Bishop d8
not here to play would before which is
completely working two people we had
computer computer line yeah he defended
in a more human way played Bishop to a6
attacking here to get get to c5
but I can just play the six and now it's
it's impossible to to move the bishop
really if you go to d8 there's some also
as this move and there there are others
it's just just too much allowing those
pawns to throw that once so it took on
d6 it takes and exchange Queens now and
played rookie to in fact this is not the
toughest defense black can try a move
like work to date
but after let's say rookie one Ruby 6 I
get biforn at the end I still have the
the b-pawn as the final winning winning
pawn also it's an additional problem
that all those pawns are weak if black
hair would have had some normal healthy
pawn structure it's still yeah it
probably is still winning from white so
it's pawn after all but this makes it
much easier because I have some ideas to
use the weekend squares like a Knight to
f5 at some point is good on attacking
the pawns so this is some still the
toughest defensive play groupie to but
after night before I had won a second
porn there was already a bit of a time
trouble for black I took him and we had
this simplification now I'm two pawns up
and black has no particular compensation
Ruby 893 he cannot take head this if he
takes I'm just promoting the form
so 90m night at five king of adi black
still cannot take if you want to take
here d 790 m rupee one as is winning for
white so it's not a very very difficult
technical task here i also could have
played this happen but I had planned 94
beforehand
it simply threatens to get into a rout
ending ending with with the capture
which wins easily he only has one move
this also this idea it's just it's the
retreat rook e1 and tending d7 and rook
e8 and now I just have the ideal
configuration the night is yeah ideally
placed here it covers the pawn and I can
just advance behind that after this
there was Ruby 7 is just which is easier
took check looking here and before I
basically didn't have time to resign
before because he he didn't have time on
the clock and here after some further
checks the Sun is basically same entity
resigned so the the key point here was
this piece sacrifice with 95 this is
very important motif to remember when if
you've got an extra pawn very often that
it's not very often but it can be an
idea to to create protected or good to
create strong pawns in the center
especially if you got two pawns very
often the compensation is is excellent
in this case I think what is better and
after the piece heck but the main point
is that it's just a very thankless
defensive task for black so white is
also much easier to play him
so nice victory um alright this the two
of my my wins and but very important
game was against the the second place at
the end grandmaster will have to have
played him with black and I'm going to
pull up the game now all right so I
loaded this game and this time I've got
black and this was played in the 8th
round eight of the penultimate round at
black as mentioned and okay this is this
is a very strong gme he's rated to five
2530 but this is one of his lowest
ratings and recently SE already had
passed two thousand six hundred two or
three years ago so he had some some
weaker events and lost some rating
points but a very strong gem and with
black okay I was content with the draw
at this point but you never know what's
going to happen he played d4 it's a
regular default player and isolate the
BOGO I mean if you look at my channel if
you watch my channel you know that I'm
writing a book about this opening so
this is the perfect place to test this I
played the check the boku 92 this is
what he always plays Knight bTW - very
often getting the bishop am here in my
book I have a main recommendation
castles and a secondary option d6 and
this is actually what I play d6 castle
this may be the theoretically better
move but to be honest I have written
this chapter in the book but I have
forgotten quite a bit of the very sharp
very variations that I analyzed and
before the game I only felt fit to to
look at my secondary line with d6 and
this is a fine line as well but it's
probably not so reliable also
interesting as their castles
um so d6 was my choice I also wanted to
play if possible slightly slightly
offbeat line not one of the main lines
as he is more likely to have something
prepared them
okay d6 this actually let him think a
couple of minutes so this was good here
obviously hasn't studied this in some
detail d6 is very flexible it allows for
various setups one idea of course is to
play e5 at some point but this is not a
given I also have some other ideas as we
see in the game after one it played a 3m
white of course can also go g3 or e3 the
various ideas a3 is the principle one of
the principle moves getting the bishop
immediately of course I cannot retreat I
need to take check and he captured with
the Queen which is maybe looking strange
to some to some people but it's a very
common way to recapture here the idea is
that the bishop on the long run wants to
go oops not there wants to go to be to
anyway so you don't want to capture here
if you want the bishop on the long
diagonal so the idea is go with the
Queen and then later fianchetto the
bishop okay I played 97 ng3 normal way
to develop yeah here I decided to go for
a b6 setup instead of an e5 setup which
is perfectly all right
b6 Bishop g2 and Bishop d7 we see that
black has given up the bishop pair but
in return has a very healthy and
flexible setup I can think about various
ways to later set up my center I can
still play e5 at some point d5 c5 so I'm
flexible haven't really committed to
pawn structure yet and I think here he
come
slight um yeah slight mistake even I
think the best move now is just castles
he played before however this this is a
bit strange because after a five which
are played white only has the choice
between two menus you can play b5 or
Bishop b2 and b5 is not really what you
want to play because it it alters your
pawn structure in an unfavorable way
because c4 c5 is more difficult to play
now as it doesn't have the support from
the before pawn and if you imagine that
at some point I play e5 let's for
argument's sake I put it on the board
White has the problem of of this pawn he
doesn't really want to move it or let it
being taken because let's say after this
the whole Queen side is blocked and I
have an excellent square on c5 can go
here and have no problems at all so you
don't want to play b5 and this wasn't
his intention he played we should be too
but now after the capture as I capture
on a1 he was fast to recapture with the
bishop if you now envision this whole
sequence of moves with castles played
first then he would have had the
possibility to take with the rook if
both sides have castled this means also
that after his castles oops this was too
much e here if instead of before he
plays castles I probably would have
played a fire first but just for
argument's sake if you look at this in
comparison now he can recapture with the
rook and this is of course much more
comfortable then taking with the bishop
has the Bishop misplaced in the corner
so this is how it happens check and here
in fact I play him I play an interesting
interesting move it's a fairly common
motif in this in the structure not
strictly necessary but interesting I
played the move b5 Ian the idea of this
move is to dislodge the c4 pawn and
fight for the light squares and white
really doesn't have a big choice he
needs to take the pawn
otherwise I will take myself on yeah
that's a c5 is also bad the idea is
simply to make sure that this bishop has
a strong diagonal that's never d4 d5
here anymore
he needs to take really ante he also
played this quickly takes takes castles
castles and yeah now I'm down but I have
excellent pieces those squares are
controlled by the bishop and by the
night yes he never would we'll be
playing d5 and those two pawns well
they're not really strong I am
I was really optimistic here twin b8
group c1 attacking the C pawn and rook
c8 covering it so this is very very
logical and now we see a really a
typical maneuver for this position
he played Bishop f1 yeah white bishop f1
the problem is how do you actually make
progress is right um you don't really
want to move the knight let's say rupee
91 as I can simply capture and even get
b5 back easily but in general exchanging
the bishop is not a great idea
as the light squares are my strong suit
anyway also you don't want to give up
the bishop pair so easily this means
that if you want to move the knight ever
you need to move the bishop first and
this is why I played you should have won
the ideas to even remove the night maybe
here maybe here and then think about f3
and f4
spending in the center you need to
remove the pieces to be able to do that
so this is why Bishop everyone here
played Bishop to a8 I briefly considered
to take him this kind of setup and then
imagine the knight coming to d5 this is
in fact a very a sturdy kind of fortress
where the Knights simply block the
further pawn advances but it is a very
passive setup and I didn't really want
to get into such a passive position it's
not so bad but it's yeah it's simply not
a very positive way to play it's just
trying to yeah to to curl up to stay
there in a dead weight it's not not very
active so I played Bishop to aah trying
to get the pawn back and he played 91 as
expected affirmed now Queen takes b5 I
played that he played f3 and in fact
this is a good idea he wants to expand
with reform I didn't think too long he
played Queen b6 putting the Queen in
this diagonal and yeah here I actually
believed he needed to play III and then
let's say III and then it was my
attention to play Bishop here and
possibly Bishop to b5 and I was quite
happy about my position it's it's not
there are not any structural problems in
blacks position I've got one pawn island
I've got no bad piece here and I
probably with Bishop b5 have chances to
get rid of one of the bishops so this
was something that I I liked
however in this position we played the
move 93 which immediately I thought wow
isn't this a mistake and I rather
quickly played the movie 5 here
utilizing this
spin and it turns out that if five was
was a mistake and this was the only yet
to be honest the only really substantial
mistake that I made in this tournament I
think I played rather solid chess and
didn't make any any big ones the big
blunders or something but this is this
is really a mistake but he didn't really
he didn't really saw how to how to make
use of that in fact after a five he
played Knight f2 and offered the drop
and this actually it was a bit of a yeah
a common misunderstanding so I thought
if I was strong and he believed me and
after Knight f2 he offered to draw and
of course I thought he blundered and he
five was the move that actually gave me
the advantage softer not f2 e is
offering the draw thinking his worst
which is true after night after we is
worse and this is also why after Knight
who I declined to draw it it's not so
easy to to decline the draw against the
strong GM it always takes a bit of a bit
of persuasion where you need to tell
yourself a writer just decline it and
play for win but ok let's not be too
quick here the thing is instead of not
f2 he had a very strong moves that we
both didn't see I mean I saw the move
but I didn't I didn't see the real point
of it he could have played to reform the
the real point is that after he takes d4
he has got Knight f2 and now this bishop
is attacking the pawn and c5 is just
just leading to nothing he can just take
it because of this this bloody pinned on
the c4 and this it seems that maybe he
missed that I'm not sure the other thing
is which I actually thought would be a
good idea
d5 ya intending to take he has got
tonight to c5 and this also needs to UM
to some trouble for like it's it's not
the lost position or so but it's it gets
me into trouble very complicated though
I probably need to move the rook
somewhere here and let's say Bishop
Pearson at the end 26 he has ideas to to
win a pawn here something like that but
this is not not a decisive advantage yet
because of opposite colored bishops so
there's still some some hope left but if
he would have played played that the
city for most maybe this tournament
would have gone another way
however he played Knight f2 with with
this draw offer and what I declined and
play to you form yeah why why declined
the draw from it's it's just with a form
that why doesn't have much choice he can
play therefore which is rather passive
and yeah getting into a closed position
I have some nice ideas I can play in
here D 5 C 6 Queen back and not be 64 I
have all kinds of ideas mostly based on
the fact that this Bishop on a1 is just
looking at its own phone here I think it
generally he didn't want to have a close
position he just took me from recaptured
and took here so what I envisioned here
was a position where I have a strong
Bishop here and here's another place for
the night or Bishop BEC Knight to e4 I
want to use those light squares so my am
yeah
declining the draw offer was based on
this fact that I have great light square
control but he now defends excellently
really played Bishop h3
immediately getting into this here and
now I didn't want to play f5 which looks
like the normal response I didn't want
to do that because of one point is Queen
g5 possibly entering to e7 and that's
also the move d4 which is not easy to
play he's opening up the position here
let's say I take bishop takes and it's
it's not easy at all
so f5 I didn't want to play so I went
through p8 just just covering that and
now I played Queen g5 which is also good
news it's attacking attacking the rook
and yeah I need to do something about
that
so I played Knight to f6 this way
covering and now Queen a5 this was his
idea
activating the Queen and pressurizing
the pawn on c7
okay I'd saw that but I saw that before
and played 95 so I'm getting to this
great piece configuration yeah white is
nothing better to than them to exchange
Queens takes and now I played Bishop to
c3 yeah he saw that a 1 is his worst
piece and he tries to activate it by a
d2 possibly to to our form so I played
f5 here there should be 2 and maybe here
is a point where I could could improve
but it's not it's not it's not really a
really trivial of course after declining
the draw of I sort of have the moral if
you want an obligation to try for
something I wanted to try for something
I really this was round 8 we both had 6
out of 7 and if I would have won the
game then I basically had the tournament
in the back so or the other way around
if he wins he
in the back so it was a very important
game of course yeah maybe here I should
have played rukka age this is maybe the
better better try try to to enter here
on the iPhone you can try to defend with
Bishop f4 attacking here after that I
need to take and okay - yeah something
like this I wasn't sure I mean I
considered this and I thought okay I'm
better here but in the other position I
thought I'm better as well because what
I wanted to do is like King here so that
after Bishop f4 I can actually just
cover it I didn't want to exchange my
excellent night for this for this Bishop
because the knight is the piece that
should capture the pawn at some point
but maybe this was wasn't so great he
now took the chance to open the position
she formed g6
takes Andrew k1 and now he tries to to
enter here and um yeah as it turns out
after King e6 king of two rook c8 a7
White has some counter play here I could
have firm played played better actually
but we see that to see that soon Roxy -
was good
King he won but now my edges are also
due to my better king is king asam
obviously passive only one and plate
would be to took here take on V form the
check check King before this is all very
very very logical Bishop f4 and here was
the last chance to to get
something and so I think retained maybe
some edge it's not cleared probably it's
a draw anyway but here I should should
take on default with the king and after
group takes g6 plane 95 to to block the
check and then my be bonus is the Trump
to deflate my B point is probably
somewhat more dangerous than his age
possibly because of this this
configuration here but I didn't I didn't
really see that the only thing that I
saw is that um I spoiled some of my edge
here and I gave the check and he had his
check and offered a draw which he
accepted um also due to the fact that he
was down to little time just just a
minute or something that has simply had
more time um after the check I get I get
the pawn and there's not not so much so
much happening so I'm a draw and this
this important game
I was I was rather satisfied with the
game only after a little bit with the
computer right after the game I was
quite disappointed I thought I had the
really big advantage but the computer
doesn't really see or points out a huge
improvement where I could have won like
instantly there was only a wide
selection of possibilities that are all
good in a way but not the winning
outright okay but the draw is a good
good result and obviously was enough at
the end to to win the tournament of
course I would have liked you to do
something great in this game but drawers
is a good result and also it was a good
test for this opening which will be
featured in
coming book alright three games from
this ya great tournament success that I
had just yeah three days ago the final
round was played in Austria I hope you
enjoyed those games and game fragments
and yeah I will back soon with some
other non blitz content probably from
the World Cup trying to feature some
games from the World Cup thanks for
watching